dass er diesmal machen wir es wieder ich
bin jetzt immer noch im hörsaal die
nachfrage nach präsenz eigentlich
besonders ausgeprägt zu sein also weiß
ich nicht ob ich damit fortsetzen will
jedenfalls ich bin aber trotzdem
verpflichtet auch bei einer ganz wenigen
zuhörern auf die hygiene vorschriften zu
verweisen
und das bedeutet dann schon dass sie
bitte mir sagen oder vielleicht können
sie meine e mails schicken dass sie wer
sie sind also wollen wir die anderen
beiden sind weiß ich aber wenn sie mir
eine e-mail schicken weiter ist dem
pflicht eine präsenz liste zu spare ich
anführen
ok na gut jetzt es geht weiter um die
thematik dies konnte indes kontinuität
in der politischen philosophie und ich
letztes mal sagt ist unser ansatz
philosophisch in erster linie und dann
[Musik]
richten wir unseren blick auf die
politische theorie
hintergrund ist der die frage was ist
über politische veränderung ist das
möglich ist vor allem ein radikaler
neubeginn möglich oder denkbar ich meine
das ist etwas was sie uns alle
gewissermaßen vorstellen
wir befinden uns in einer welt sie die
irgendwie im sich systematisch im kreis
zu drehen scheint wo es eigentlich
dringend notwendig wäre da rauszukommen
im hinblick beispielsweise auf
klimawandel
unter anderem dies ist das system gesagt
sagt also es wird ausgesprochen von der
wirtschaft von der industrie na ja wir
brauchen zehn jahre in zehn jahren
können wir vielleicht ein bisschen was
erreichen dass bestimmte bereiche
ebenfalls klimaneutral werden
demgegenüber stellt man sich vielleicht
die frage ja also gegen ginge es nicht
schneller
und wenn es nicht schneller geht
brauchen wir dann ein ganz anderes
system müssen wir wieder neu anfangen
und nicht immer neues sagen na ja wir
haben schon eine eingerichtete geordnete
welt und das ist dann die vorbedingungen
dafür dass sie überhaupt was machen gut
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts wie
wir letzte woche schon angesprochen
hatten war eben der gedanken eigentlich
müsste ist schon möglich sein neu zu
beginnen das haben schließlich die
russen gemacht nach der revolution in
den 20er jahren und die die sie auch die
philosophische spekulation in dieser
zeit hat sich sehr mit dieser frage
beschäftigt wie kommen wir jetzt raus
aus diesem schlamassel aus dem aus
manchem sicht mancher leute aus diesem
korrupten politischen system das wir was
neues anfangen können und sind wir
überhaupt oft auf die fortsetzung des
alten angewiesen oder können wir nicht
einfach ganz rein und frisch neu
beginnen
gut also die der hintergrund dazu ist
mit sicherheit die die russische
revolution und die theorien die im
zusammenhang mit der russischen
revolution entstanden sind ich habe das
mal
erwähnt linien und den will ich jetzt
gleich ansprechen
trotzdem vorher noch ein paar
bemerkungen zu dieser thematik des
neubeginns
ich habe letzte woche schon die
theoretischen überlegungen von sören
kierkegaard erwähnt gebe gar dem
theologischen bereich der sagt oder
theologisch philosophischen kritiker
regel ist regel für die aufsässigen für
die revolutionäre des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts war alles was an dem alten
system nicht gestimmt hat also hegel war
der grund trends der preußischen staat
philosophen aus deren sicht weil er
und das war quasi das fundament seiner
darstellung den preußischen staat als
ergebnis eines einer historischen
entwicklung dargestellt hat also der
preußische staat ist zwar noch nicht
unbedingt perfekt und verwendet aber
dort arbeitet der geist und der geist
ist diese intelligenz die sich im
menschlichen sachen manifestiert und
speziell in der politik langsam aber
unablässig in richtung
ja wenn nicht utopie jedenfalls an der
perfekten staatsform sich heran arbeitet
gut also das war aus vielerlei sieht
sich für viele denker einfach nicht
akzeptabel also der gedanke dass wir
jetzt innerhalb beim bei den beim
preußischen der preußischen monarchie
und weiter geht's nicht
das war aus vielen perspektiven nicht
akzeptabel kirche gott wie ich letzte
woche schon erwähnt habe sagt aus der
theologischen perspektive passt das
nicht
also die welt ist nicht ein system ein
gottgegebenes system also übrigens das
ist bei kirkuk ist dass sie diese
radikale protestantismus als katholik
hätte er das vielleicht befürwortet also
hegels gedanke des geistes in devils ist
eigentlich eine katholische thematik war
kein katholik ist egal das war die
letzte woche sagte diese metaphysischen
themen tauchen überall auf die sind
nicht von vornherein belegt mit
irgendwelchen politischen oder
theologischen
etiketten der gedanke gottes in der welt
realisiert sich in der geschichte also
bei hegel geist ist etwas was jedenfalls
in der mainstream katholische theologie
durchaus akzeptabel wäre für kik gehört
als protestant ist es aber nicht
akzeptabel für kirkegaard ist es ganz
der ganze punkt des christentums im
gegensatz zu anderen anderen religionen
vielleicht naja gut lassen was dabei
aber im gegen das alles das was das
christentum auszeichnet für kirche gott
ist diese der abrupte neu begeben und
zwar er sagt schockierend das ist
beleidigend
also so wie jesus erscheint als als sohn
eines armen mannes der auch mit [ __ ]
und
und steuer einsammeln und anderen
schrecklichen leuten sich aufhält das
ist eine beleidigung es ist absolut
nicht erwartet das ist nicht quasi der
triumphierend hält der aus dem als der
dem fortschritt gottes in der welt
entsteht sondern er ist einfach neu und
eine eine eine radikal neue existenz gut
also dass ist jetzt das argument und das
ist etwas was für kirche dort absolut
unvereinbar ist mit dem hegelschen
gedanken und hildegard nimmt dieses
motiv auf das ich letzte woche schon
erwähnt habe das motiv des augenblicks
augenblick ist es der ort ist eigentlich
kein ort ist wieder ort noch zeit aber
es ist der punkt der dimension slow zz
ausdehnung lose punkt wo plötzlich war
es anders wird
sorry ich habe scheinbar nicht ich hab
doch auf alle züge alle zu lassen
die anderen sind wohl zu spät gekommen
ok ich hoffe sie sind jetzt alle da
probleme mit mit zu sorry das war meine
schuld
na gut also die diejenigen die ich
gerade jetzt reingelassen haben möchten
sich bitte bei auf der homepage bei der
aufnahme informieren falls falls sie
wollen okay also jetzt noch mal für
kirkegaard und wie gesagt gerade ist
theologisch aber bei kirche gott ist ist
der ort des wandels oder des neubeginns
oder der ort wo etwas wertvolles
plötzlich in die welt in die realität
eintritt ist etwas was nicht
ergebnis einer eines systematisches
thematischen entwicklung gelten kann
oder drauf dieser bruch der den man ganz
deutlich bei kirche gott sieht und im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert zu einem einem
serie zu einer sehr kräftigen entfaltung
kommt ist ein ganz starker bruch mit dem
was bisher also stand anfang des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts in der
europäischen philosophie entstanden war
also der gedanke ich habe letzte woche
erwähnt in der in der antike haben sich
die philosophen den kopf zerbrochen mit
paradoxien der verrät er es dass der
bewegung 10 an der veränderung was ist
überhaupt veränderungen kann ich wie
kann ich veränderungen verstehen wie es
wirkliche veränderung etwas was
überhaupt in meinen kopf rein geht
sozusagen das ist paradox
im gegensatz zu plump nationalistischen
idealismus der davon ausgeht es gibt
transzendente ewige unteilbare
realitäten und darum geht es ja ok
im siebzehnten und achtzehnten
jahrhundert in der westlichen fiel in
der europäischen philosophie hat man
dachte man gerade man hätte das problem
der veränderung begriff und das sieht
man dann beispielsweise bei leibnitz in
zweierlei form also leibnitz mit der
international rechnung wie man wandlung
berechnet und auf eine formel reduziert
dass der igh die eine seite bei leuten
ist die andere seite bei leibnitz ist
der gedanke ist der satz vom
zureichenden grunde also alles was
passiert hat einen grund für leidet und
deswegen dieses system hat dieses system
das sich
unabänderlich voran wälzt oder na ja gut
das verändert sich schon aber auf eine
regel regelmäßige weise die wir
philosophisch ergreifen können und das
ist etwas was man bei kant auch findet
weil die kausalität bei kant
vorbedingungen ist überhaupt für das
verstehen der welt und bei hegel ist die
kausalität oder die systematische
entwicklung eben das was geschichte
auszeichnet ok dagegen jetzt wehrt sich
erstmal hier kirche gott nicht nur aber
lasst uns das erst mal bei kirche gott
weil er auch als als vor allem als
vorreiter des existenzialismus 1960
jahrhundert gilt und auch gerade die
themen des des den begriff augenblick
sehr selbst sehr eingehend behandelt hat
ok jetzt augenblick es ist der
augenblick wo oder der begriff
augenblick und das was man philosophisch
daraus machen könnte
der jetzt für unsere leute erst mal
nicht in eine wichtige rolle spielt das
sind dann unsere leute band mit unseren
leuten meine ich erstmal schmidt und
beide wie schon gesagt auf ganz anderem
pumpen des des politischen spektrums der
eine chor ist der nazis schnitt und der
andere
jude und und kampf genauso von brecht
also ganz was anderes aber beide beide
interessiert an dieser frage der des
neubeginns und der ort des neubeginns
als augenblick das werden wir uns jetzt
gleich anschauen aber zuerst noch ein
kleines bisschen hintergrund diesmal zur
politischen theorie nicht zur metaphysik
wichtig ausschlag in fundamental für die
entwicklung im europäischen so jetzt
noch mal etwas anderes in der
europäischen politischen tradition ab
sagen wir mal lockt schon lockt dem
englischen philosophen im späteren neues
siebzehnten jahrhundert ist der gedanke
des liberalen rechtsstaates also der
rechtsstaat der dann auch vielfältige
entwicklungen erfährt der rechtsstaat
ist der staat wo das recht primär ist
der rechtsstaat ist ein staat der auf
dem boden oder unter der vorherrschaft
des rechts entsteht zuerst das recht
dann der start und das hat dann
vielfältige ausprägungen bei lok log
kommt aus dem aus dem aus dem
jahrhundert der revolutionen oder des
bürgerkrieges in england und da ging es
um den konflikt zwischen zunächst mal
zwischen den könig james jakob den
ersten und dem parlament und jakob hat
gesagt oder james hat gesagt
ich bin euer richter also ich bin die
quelle des rechts
er war auch ein sehr gelehrter mona
reich so ist es nicht aber nicht dumm
aber aus und aus seiner theorie hat er
hat gesagt dass die quelle des gesetzes
bin doch ich also das ist der
absolutismus gewissermaßen aber james
argument ist also wo wollt ihr jetzt
sonst gucken
ich bin halt der souverän ich bin der
monarch
es gibt keine andere quelle nein sagt
sagten seine gegner vor allem der jurist
cook ca doch es gibt schon eine andere
quelle an diese andere quelle ist das
gemeine recht kommen auf englisch also
das gemeine recht hat nicht das gleiche
den gleichen status in deutschland aber
trotzdem gab es auch in preußen
bis ende des 19 jahrhunderts das gemeine
recht ist diese tradition ja was heißt
tradition tradition ist abwärts und der
gedanke mit dem gemeinen recht mit
common law ist dass es gibt bestimmte
prinzipien denen wir keinen ursprung
zuordnen können
das ist das wichtige an gemeinden recht
ist wir können nicht sagen ja im
gegensatz zum statuarischen reicht also
zu gesetzen beim gemeinen recht können
wir nicht sagen ja also dieser dieser
vorschrift hat seinen ursprung in irgend
einem jahr oder hat irgendein könig oder
parlament oder irgendwas verfügt sondern
es war halt sei es war halt immer so
auf englisch heißt dass since time
immemorial also seid unvergänglichen
zeit ja und das ist ein kriterium also
immer eine ob das jetzt ist es mehr als
tradition also wichtig ist es mehr als
tradition es ist wenn man sagt das sind
einfach absolute nicht hinterfragbar
prinzipien ja das war dann der konflikt
der dann in diesem bürgerkrieg
hineingeführt hat in england der damit
endete dass das parlament gewonnen hat
und damit auch das prinzip des kommen
landes kommen neue im nächsten
jahrhundert oder der gedanke es gibt
bestimmte unerschütterliche grundlegende
prinzipien die ich nicht hinterfragen
kann das fließt dann natürlich in die in
die geistigen strömungen die dann das
französische revolution die französische
revolution auslösen und auch die
amerikanische revolution und aber dort
haben sie ein etwas anderer gestalt da
heißt sie dann menschenrechte es gibt
wie gesagt im angelsächsischen fängt an
mit kommen und entwickelt sich weiter
und wird dann zu menschenrechten aber im
grunde ist es beides dasselbe ist es der
gedanke es gibt bestimmte unhinterfragt
baarer prinzipien also prinzipien die so
fundiert dass man gar nicht feststellen
kann wo sie herkommen
es ist einfach so okay das ist jetzt der
liberale rechtsstaat und innerhalb des
des rechtsstaates hat man bestimmte
mechaniken sich ausgedacht wie man sich
dann halten könnte ist am einfachsten
ist es man sagt einfach es gibt halt die
menschenrechte dass es gibt oder bzw
besser gesagt es gibt also in der
deutschen im deutschen system es gibt
grund errichtet und diese grundrecht
sind unumstößlich und unveränderlich und
gelten für immer
und dann muss da muss sich jeder dran
halten
das ist eine möglichkeit die andere
möglichkeit die er so ein bisschen die
englische
oder die amerikanische lösung ist naja
ich meine die amerikaner haben auch
menschenrechte im erhöhten ausmaße
gegenüber den engländern also für die
engländer gelten die menschenrechte
zunächst nicht das ist etwas was über
sprechen werden im zusammenhang mit
edmund burke aber es gibt trotzdem also
in england gibt es eine doppelte
systematik zum einen gibt es die
kommende prinzipien die nicht
unumstößlich sind im sinne des der
menschenrechte es wäre theoretisch
denkbar vielleicht common law prinzipien
auszusetzen denkbar so theorie sehr
unwahrscheinlich aber aber denkbar aber
wichtiger ist es gibt unumstößliche
prozedur also dass das englische die
englische systematik die auch
gewissermaßen in deutschland übernommen
worden ist oder was heißt übernommen
parallel entstanden ist ist der prozedur
alis muss also es gibt inhalte nämlich
die grundrechte und dann gibt es auch
prozedur die ebenfalls für immer gelten
müssen
dies sind aber nicht ganz so einfach
festzunageln und vor allem in england
läuft es oft darauf hinaus dass diese
prozeduren eigentlich nur konventionen
sind also das ist das was man auf den
engländern vorwirft dass die verfassung
in england nur zum teil geschrieben ist
weil wie man sich verhält das sind
konventen verhaltensmuster und nicht
unbedingt
geschriebene anweisungen und das ist
etwas sie darum was im angelsächsischen
bereich in schwierigkeiten führen kann
zum beispiel auch gerade jetzt ist nicht
in england sondern in amerika also wenn
trump jetzt sagt nein ich trete nicht
zurück
das entspricht ganz und gar nicht den
konventionen des politischen lebens die
sich jetzt seit jahren etabliert haben
aber das sind ja nur kommerz ist
konventionen ich kann nicht darüber
hinwegsetzen
es ist nirgendwo festgeschrieben dass
ich jetzt jetzt schon sagen muss ja der
beiden hat gewonnen
muss ich nicht ich sage hat nicht
geworden ich soll weiterhin ich habe
gewonnen
ja es wäre ich meine das ist seit
gründung der amerikanischen staaten ist
das des amerikanischen staates ist das
nie vorgekommen und insofern ist es
eigentlich undenkbar und unmöglich weil
eben das amerikanische system auf
konventionen beruht teilweise weniger
als in england aber viel mehr als in
deutschland
die man einfach so aushebeln kann
wenn es einem passt ok also die
schwierigkeit ist oder was eine
schwierigkeit hier gibt es bereich wo
man davon ausgeht dass es existieren
regel die den einzelnen vorgängen im
staat vorausgehen
die sind schon da
und an dieser regel muss man sich halten
egal ob es jetzt prozedurale regeln sind
oder vorstellungen von menschenrechten
das ist eine grundlage eine grund ebene
die voraussetzung ist für die politik
überhaupt ok und das ist der liberale
rechtsstaat und jetzt kommen wir ins
zwanzigste jahrhundert mit wie gesagt
nach dem ersten weltkrieg das gefühl das
kann so nicht weitergehen
die russen haben es vorgemacht mit ihrer
revolution was machen wir jetzt so der
text den man gelesen hat zunächst mal
ist wie ich letzte woche schon erwähnte
lehnen ihn ins text staat und revolution
das ist kein besonders langer text aber
es ist jenes interpretation des
marxismus geschrieben in dem jahr in dem
monaten bevor er dann nach selber aus
aus aus der schweiz nach russland gehen
um die revolution der bolschewiki der
bolschewiken anzuführen
okay er hat das so dargestellt
das was er jetzt macht und was dann was
die ich meine man hatte ja eine einen
aufstand einer revolution schon im
februar 1917 gegeben
das war der nach lenins darstellung der
aufstand der mensch ewg also der
porsche weg heißt mehr menschen weg
minderheit aber aus
lennys darstellung sind das die
wesentlichen die sozialdemokraten die
bürgerlichen sozialdemokraten haben zwar
einen aufstand erfolgreich durchgeführt
in russland anfang des jahres 1917
aber sie bleiben noch dem alten
bürgerlichen dort verhaftet und sie
hätten sagt ist
lenins vorwurf sie hätten marx so
interpretiert dass marx dann als lieber
im wesentlichen als liberaler
bürgerlicher denker zu verstehen wäre
insbesondere weil die lenins gegner sagt
lienen geglaubt hätten
man muss jetzt nur den staat übernehmen
und reformieren
dann hätten wir alles was wir brauchen
ja also der staat bisher hat die reichen
grundbesitzer oder die pedalen herren
oder wen auch immer favorisiert aber wir
jetzt also die sozialdemokraten hätten
gesagt ja dass wir müssen den status
übernehmen und dann halten
es kommen andere sind dann nicht mehr
die adeligen die dann die länge die
lenkungs positionen dem staat einnehmen
sondern wir sind dann also wir die
bürgerlichen und dann gerade mal den
staat reformieren und dann haben wir die
revolution und mehr brauchen wir nicht
okay linie sache nein das geht nicht und
lenins punkt ist ob das versucht das mit
zitaten aus marx und engels zu
untermauern aber es ist schon ein sehr
wichtiger schritt gegenüber den
sozialdemokraten linien sagt nein das
geht nicht weil der staat so wie er ist
ist nur ausdruck von einem und nämlich
davon dass das bürgertum ist in dem fall
seit februar militärisches versucht ihre
interessen durchzusetzen also der staat
ist das instrument der gegenrevolution
ja okay und deswegen sagt liening ganz
brauchen wir einen totalen neubeginn und
dieser neu bekannten beginnen beruht auf
sagen mal drei punkten sind drei punkte
die dabei in staat und revolution
deutlich werden das erste was ich letzte
woche schon bestellt seine welt hatte
ist die unversöhnlichkeit also die
unversöhnlichkeit also es sagt der staat
ist das produkt und die äußerung der
unversöhnlichkeit der klassengegensätze
ja der staat entsteht dort dann und
insofern wo wann und inwiefern die
klassengegensätze objektiv nicht
versöhnt werden können
ok also das ist unüberbrückbar
der staat so wie er jetzt ist ist nur
die waffe der bursch was jetzt macht
überhaupt keinen sinn diesem staat zu
übernehmen er kann nicht er kann nicht
reformiert werden weil er eben der
stoßtrupp der bürgerlichen gegenüber dem
arbeiten darstellt ich muss nicht
übernommen werden oder reformiert
sondern er muss überwältigt ja und
deswegen ist der zweite punkt dass die
waffengewalt essentiell ist was man
braucht sagt er ist eine selbsttätige
bewaffnete organisation der bevölkerung
das ist so quasi der ideale punkt es ist
übrigens interessant also diese frage
mit den waffen aber heutzutage
jedenfalls in europa sagt man sich auch
wie das ist etwas was die amerikaner die
amerikaner sind alle waffennarren sind
besessen von der vorstellung wir
brauchen waffen und das wird verstanden
als irgendwie ein psychisches leiden
dass man dass man diese vorstellung hat
das ist natürlich nicht ganz korrekt
weil es ist schon richtig dass in der
amerikanischen verfassung fordert
manager eine rolle spielt also dass
bewaffnete das volk soll sich schon
bewaffnen dürfen und das ist ein
politisches ziel ein politisches ideal
in der amerikanischen verfassten
verfassung um zu verhindern eben genau
das was lenin sagt dass nämlich der
staat ich habe jetzt einen punkt
übersprungen
für linien ist erscheint der staat oder
die die organe des staates sind
zweierlei das eine ist die bürokratie
und die andere das andere ist das
militär und das militär gerade weil der
staat ein
eigenes militär besitzt ist es
essenziell sagt linie und das genau die
gleiche meinung
der gleichen meinung waren auch die
amerikanischen siedler die kolonisten im
18 jahrhundert gegen england genau
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir uns
auch bewaffnen
also wir dass eine bewaffnete volks
bewaffnete falls verbände haben in dem
sinne schon einen positiven beigeschmack
dass man könnte sagen also bei allem
fehlenden verständnis dafür dass wir
unbedingt schusswaffen im keller
aufbewahren sollte oder oder was auch
immer
also das prinzip ist vielleicht gerade
noch nachvollziehbar die schwierigkeit
ist natürlich dass die amerikaner und
eigentlich wahrscheinlich auch lenin
nicht vorausgesehen haben das dass die
gewehre die flinten oder was auch immer
das war damals hatte natürlich ganz
anders sind als vollautomatische
sturmgewehre heute insofern jetzt
quantität in qualität das hat eine
andere qualität als es damals gehabt
hätte aber es ist ebenfalls trotzdem
interessant hier sind parallele also
wenn lenin sagt ja das volk das
proletariat muss sich bewaffnen für uns
heute ist das ein bisschen schockierend
oder das schwer vorzustellen wie das
jetzt gehen soll ohne dass sofort blut
terror und chaos ausbricht aber damals
vielleicht weniger und auf jeden fall
ist ist etwas was eine schon
vielleicht respektable parallelen in
amerika schon hatte okay aber ebenfalls
wichtig ist auch wenn man quasi ein
bisschen bagatellisieren sollte bei
linien also warf er ist waffe war für
ist darum leute zu schießen also da kann
man nicht drum herum
insofern ist spricht lenin schon für
gewalt also gewalt waffengewalt ist ein
element seiner veränderung also für ihn
es ist nicht nur die gegensätze sind
unversöhnlich der klassenkampf der
richtige klassenkampf sozusagen ist ein
richtiger kampf und es lässt sich hier
die eine klasse oder die andere muss
gewinnen also der grund für diese oder
was jetzt passieren wird ist dass das
proletariat macht der bursch was sie das
lebensrecht streitig es ist schon ein
kampf also es kommt jetzt nur ein
gewinner dabei heraus dass das erste und
der zweite punkt ja und außerdem
brauchen wir
waffen und gewalt also ist es nicht so
dass er da jetzt genüsslich von tod und
und mordend und leiden spricht aber er
sagt schon wir brauchen waffen und der
dritte punkt für lenin sehr wichtig ist
dass wir mehr oder weniger gerade
angesprochen hat ist das ergebnis dieser
dieses aufstandes dieses dieser
erneuerung ist eine diktatur oder sein
begriff ja es ist die diktatur des
proletariats
das ist ein modell für das was danach
kommt also das ergebnis dieser war
dieser bewaffneten auseinandersetzung
ist eine diktatur
also das kann man nicht schönreden das
ist dass der die eine gruppe nämlich
dass aufständische proletariat
gewinnt und in seinem sieg errichtet es
eine diktatur und diktatur wird auch so
beschrieben bei denen als eine die
ungeteilte war gewaltig sagt diktatur
das heißt einer mit niemand geteilten
und sich unmittelbar auf die bewaffnete
gewalt der massen stützende macht ja
also hier ist nichts liberale ist
sozusagen kein sagt nicht also wir
werden dann die menschenrechte
durchsetzen oder sonst als sondern hier
ist es geht es nur ganz konkret um die
diktatur des proletariats also die
annahme ist dass das proletariat von
humana mit anderen menschen umgehen wird
vielleicht alles nicht er es mit ist die
branche was sie vorher bisher aber
trotzdem ist jetzt eine diktatur des
proletariats muss erst mal da ist eine
eigenen interessen durchsetzen
ohne rücksicht auf irgendwelche
abstrakten vorstellungen wie
menschenrechte und co ja okay also da
haben wir diese struktur
bye bye lenin ablehnung des
marxistischen also ob er jetzt in seiner
interpretation von marx recht hat oder
nicht also das darf man so ein bisschen
bezweifeln und deswegen heißt es auch im
hinblick auf die sowjets praxis muss
leninismus war hier kommt ein
bestandteil der im marxismus also marx
marx wie sie möglicherweise wissen also
für marx war der klassenkampf zwar schon
die dynamik der geschichte aber auch in
einem positiven sinne weil klassen für
marx entstehen
als teil der modernen produktionsmittel
also moderne technik moderne
gesellschaftliche organisationen und so
weiter machen es möglich dass der mensch
sich immer besser organisiert und für
marx ist ist der klassenkampf einfach
eine ein reflex davon dass die alten
herren also dass die feudalen heran
nicht loslassen wollen aber man drängt
sie heraus und hat dann eine moderne
organisierte demokratie und es muss
nicht bei marx also vielleicht ist es
eine revolution aber es ist nicht
unbedingt eine bewaffnete blutige kann
man sagen könnte man sache also das
haben jedenfalls die sozialdemokraten
sowie lehnen das schildert gesagt aber
das lehnt linie ab wir lehnen ist es
unversöhnlicher gegensatz es ist einfach
so entweder die eine seite lebt überlebt
oder die andere und das ist existenziell
es ist ein 1 0 punkt es ist quasi dort
wo das neue unvermittelt anfängt konnte
man sahen also ist es eigentlich nicht
ganz weil eben auch lenin sagt ja die
entwicklung des modernen kapitalismus
hat schon sehr viel gebracht und
hergestellt und darauf können wir
aufbauen also bei auch bei lehman ist
der gedanke einer kontinuität vorhanden
ja ok aber jetzt was macht mit draus
sogar schnitt sie kennen kein schnitt
sicherlich schon berühmt berüchtigt ich
habe letzte woche schon ein bisschen was
zu ihm gesagt ich würde schon im fehlen
also wenn sie es nicht schon getan haben
oder oder oder wissen dass sie
wenigstens die wikipedia eintragung
zuschnitt sich anschauen
und da ist auch da können sie auch
abrufen spiels artikel über den ruhepuls
das habe ich letzte woche schon erwähnt
aber trotzdem es ist interessant und
wichtig also der röm putsch wie sie
sicherlich wissen war dieser
auseinandersetzung zwischen im
wesentlichen zwischen der wehrmacht und
der ss hitler dann dazu gebracht wurde
oder in einer hat das auch aus eigenem
antrieb seinen alten weggefährten rom zu
liquidieren und auch im wesentlichen
auch die die ganze as a
und ich meine es im höchsten grade
unappetitlich und wurde also interessant
ist auch was ich ja doch ich glaube ich
wusste es schon ich habe ich hab gestern
mir dass die wikipedia ein tragen mir
angeschaut
das war für die führungsriege der nazi
ist das war also würde röhms schwul
schwul als das war eine richtige
verschwörung ist richtig richtiger
verschwörungstheoretiker ansatz die die
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob es himmler war
oder oder also einer von denen
jedenfalls hat das aufgebaut zu einer
verschwörungstheorie ja die schulen
kommen
und werden uns übernehmen das und rhön
ist der repräsentant einer militanten
schulen bewegung und deswegen müssen wir
ihn loswerden
also ich glaube 1000 gründe vorgeschoben
wurden warum man loswerden sollte aber
das war das der sonderbarsten von diesen
also ebenfalls finde ich ein bisschen
geben
sie ist das ist das ist quasi nur
anekdote ich hier spielt das keine große
rolle
aber schmidt wie sie wissen die römer
und die anderen führer wurden also
jedenfalls die ideen in münchen oder in
münchen und umgebung waren wurden nach
startet heim geschleppt und dort
erschossen
ohne gerichtsverfahren
also einfach so ungefähr 90 menschen
personen wurden insgesamt im zuge dieser
dieses so genannten putsches liquidiert
erschossen auch einige in dachau und ja
gut und dann kommt schnitt wie gesagt
diese extrem dieser profilierte jurist
und rechtfertig das wie gesagt also
diese das geschah alles ohne verfahren
also überhaupt kein gerichtsverfahren
sondern nur abschleppen einsperren und
erschießen mit antwort auf die frage
darf man das überhaupt war
naja der führer der führer darf ist der
führer macht ernst es ist eine
rechtfertigung wie gesagt können sie im
wikipedia über wikipedia abrufen der
führer macht ernst mit den lehrern der
deutschen geschichte also hauptsächlich
was ende des ersten weltkrieges passiert
war das gibt ihnen das recht und die
kraft einen neuen start und eine neue
ordnung zu begründen
also absoluter neu beginnen deswegen
gelten keine kontinuitäten auch keine
kontinuitäten im sinne des rechtsstaates
gerichtsverfahrens dann sagt er und das
ist wichtig dass werden sie sehen im
hinblick auf das was ich gerade gesagt
habe der führer schützt das recht vor
dem schlimmsten missbrauch wenn er jetzt
kommt im augenblick der gefahr
kraft seines führerscheins als oberster
gerichtshof unmittelbar rechts schafft
also hier haben wir diese elemente die
unmittelbarkeit also das ist ein
neubeginn
da war also alles was bisher war die die
schlimme deutsche geschichte und die
niederlage im ersten weltkrieg und die
schande
toll stoß und alles mögliche das lassen
wir haben hinter uns das gibt es einfach
nicht mehr jetzt haben wir den führer
der im augenblick der gefahr jetzt
augenblick genau im deutschen sinne
kraft seines führerscheins unmittelbar
rechts schafft also das ist die
unmittelbarkeit mittelbar wäre wenn er
irgendwie versucht hätte das mit
bestehenden rechtsprinzipien zu
rechtfertigen aber das macht der führer
nicht der führer sagt er einfach so penn
jetzt bist du tot
ja und das ist das unmittelbare schaffen
von craft und das wieder also mittelbar
unmittelbar mittelbar wäre so quasi
hygienisch hier kommt das system und
daraus daraus kann man das rechtfertigen
aber hier ist es unmittelbar und sagt ja
auch beispielsweise richterliche
unabhängigkeit das brauchen wir nicht
das ist alles bürgerliche tod und so
weiter ja gut oder er sagt gibson des
liberalismus brauchen wir nicht was wir
haben ist radikal neu
der führer ist der das vehikel des neuen
oder was auch immer jedenfalls werden
dann die götzen des liberalismus
rausgeschmissen okay das ist jetzt
natürlich sehr unattraktiv aber wie ich
letzte woche stand sagte damit will ich
jetzt nicht dem nicht schmeckte die
pfanne hauen das ist quasi ein extrem
ein ergebnis das ja das sehr zu bedauern
ist
schmidt war ja bei weitem nicht der
einzige deutsche intellektuelle der dem
faschismus verfallen ist und ich meine
wenn man sich die amerikaner jetzt
anschaut auch aus wenn intelligente
leute wie der senator lindsay graham der
eigentlich auch scheinbar in anderen
zusammenhängen netter mensch ist so sehr
dem charme verfallen ist
gut also ich meine
uns fällt es leicht solche leute zu
verurteilen aber wir sind nicht in der
situation vielleicht ich weiß es nicht
also das ist jetzt eine andere frage
aber jetzt ich will wie gesagt ich mit
jetzt nicht einfach so komplett in die
pfanne hauen er ist als denker sehr
wichtig und damit mit seinen
eigenschaften als denker setzen uns erst
mal auseinander
jetzt mache ich jetzt noch ein paar
bemerkungen so schmidt in diesem
zusammenhang
und das hat dann für heute wieder
erreichen
ok also wie gesagt lenin hat diese
diversen punkte die ich hervorgehoben
habe ausdehnen oder aus dem schnittchen
also für leni nicht aber für schmidt
macht daraus diese diesen
existenzialistischen port
existenzialistisch im zimmer kirche
gottes das jetzt metaphysisch das ganz
neue unvermittelte entsteht
das ist bei linien soll eine
radikalisierung von marx aber aber keine
metaphysische beim schnitt ist es
metaphysik bei schmidt kommt jetzt der
gedanke des absolut 9
und wie läuft das er sagt es offen also
meine man hat schon das gefühl auch bei
linien dass er sich irgendwie freut über
die den unversöhnlichen gegensatz
zwischen den klassen das ist schon
richtig aber das ist nicht das ist nicht
die grundlage seiner theorie bei schmidt
ist ist der gegensatz der politische
gegen das tatsächlich die grundlage der
theorie und das ist der punkt den sie
sicherlich schon kenne nicht wirklich so
wörtlich nicht erwähnt aber der punkt
mit dem verein mit der unterscheidung
zwischen freund und feind
diese unterscheidung freund feind der
ist mein freund
der andere ist mein feind diese
unterscheidung ist ja mit grundlegend
das ist ja bekannt bei ihm und das ist
die politische unterscheidung
schlechthin
es ist die existenzielle unterscheidung
also das ist was überhaupt politik
entstehen ist ein natürlich kaum
erfahrungen der vielleicht brauchen wir
gar keine politik und das lässt schmidt
gewissermaßen offen aber in den
zwanziger jahren im 20er und 30er jahre
in deutschland war das eigentlich war
das kein konnte das keine frage sein
weil die politik war dermaßen präsent
und und drücken dass man schon verstehen
musste worum geht es überhaupt und
schmidt sagt ganz einfach politik ist
freund und vereins wie lenin
klassengegensätze sind hier die ist hier
der gegensatz zwischen freund und feind
und was ist jetzt freund und feind bei
linien sind es ja letztendlich wird
herzlich wurzelten wurzelnden
unterschiede zwischen politik und poesie
und bei schmidt ist es nation volk ja
wir sind ein volk und die anderen die
anderen völker etwas anderes und das
sind unsere feinde und da sagte ich muss
jetzt nicht gegenüber dem meinen feinden
in dem sinne hass oder und was verspüren
ich weiß einfach weiß bloß schließen
sind heute meine feinde
das ist was anderes die bedeutend für
mich eine existenzielle bedrohung auch
wenn ich sie nicht hasse aber wenn sie
nichts gegen mich zunächst mal
unternehmen trotzdem sind meine feinde
auch das ist natürlich schwierig also im
nachhinein weil damit kann ich alles
mögliche rechtfertigen
gerade auch den rassismus also wenn ich
sagen ja gut also ich habe kenne auch
juden bei mir in der gegend wohnen auch
juden
ich habe nichts gegen sie aber es sind
halt nicht mein volk und dann werden sie
dann zu finden
also das ist schon schwierig wenn du das
klingt zunächst mal ja gut also dass er
meint mit dieser unterscheidung nicht so
dramatisch ist aber es ist um es ist
gerade deswegen wenn er sagt ich musste
nicht essen ist es noch dramatisch ok
und das führt und da ist er mit linien
in einem boot
quasi dort wo diese freundschaft sich
letztendlich artikuliert ist im krieg
aber speziell nicht allgemein kriegen
sondern wirklich im bürgerkrieg also da
folgt da auch dem dänischen ansatz hier
ist bürgerkrieg oder revolution also das
sind zwei begriffe für das eine für
schmidt ist das derselbe mehr oder
weniger eigentlich für lenin auch
bürgerkrieg und revolution das sind die
das ist der interessante punkt oder der
punkt wo dieser gegensatz in voller
wucht sozusagen entsteht ja okay und wie
gesagt also das ist das gefährliche wenn
quasi ein lückenloser übergang
stufenloser übergang zwischen neuer gut
also sind leute ich hasse sie nicht aber
es sind halt andere anderes vor
der übergang denn ich musste gar nicht
hassen aber trotzdem kann ist zu einem
bürgerkrieg kommen mit diesen feinden ja
also das ist wie sich dann schnell zeigt
das ist das ist noch viel schlimmer als
wenn ich sagte ja bitte schön wenn du
die judenhasses dann machen wir's oder
darfst du was tun also wenn wenn hier
wenn ich einfach ganz kühl sage uns halt
ein anderes folglich hat sie nicht aber
es ein anderes volk aber es ist unsere
aufgabe sie aus zum herzen weil
ansonsten werden die junge dass uns das
selber antun
ja also es ist schon erschreckend
eigentlich
ok der zweite punkt aber es ist genau
parallel mit linie
der zweite punkt ebenfalls parallel zu
lehnen ist die sache mit der waffe und
das wird dann von schmidt ganz schon
direkt und ausdrücklich in verbindung
mit töten gebracht er sagt das
wesentliche an den begriff der waffe ist
dass es sich um ein mittel physischer
tötung von menschen handelt und wir
wollen auch also wir hassen die leute
zwar nicht aber wir wollen bewaffnet
sein damit man es zum bürgerkrieg kommt
und tetra damit wir vorbereitet sind und
eine waffe ist ein mittel zitat zur
physischen tötung von menschen ja also
das hat man schon bei belene
also wie gesagt es ist nicht unbedingt
ganz so lächerlich und kinder ist wie
man das gefühl hat die amerikaner jetzt
mit ihren medien
ihren waffen aber trotz man hat darin
sind nicht um gutes gefühl
rudolf schmidt beide wollen bewaffnet
sein und zwar über das über die damals
die bewaffnung der der bürgerlichen
verbände durch die amerikaner also das
lässt sich gewissermaßen noch
nachvollziehen und vielleicht
rechtfertigen allerdings nicht mit
sturmgewehren aber in irgendeiner form
aber hier jetzt im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert direkt nach dem ersten
weltkrieg
ok also der dritte punkt auch analog zu
lenin linien sie erinnert sich der
dritte punkt ist dieser gedanke der
diktatur bei schmidt ist es der gedanke
der totalen herrschaft total und
souverän sagt im ernstfall total weil
jeder angelegenheit potenziell politisch
sein kann und zweitens der mensch in der
politischen teilnahme ganz und
existenziell erfasst wird dann sagt
schmidt die politik ist das schicksal
bei
bei linien wie gesagt diktatur weil es
geht nur dass das notariat ist die
poesie ausschaltet und das mit waffen
okay kann man nicht anders machen
bei schmitt ist es dann schon noch einen
schritt weiter metaphysisch weil
verwendet das begriff der den begriff
der schritt des schicksals schicksal das
werde ich nächste woche mit ihnen
besprechen aber schicksal ist etwas was
sich im augenblick zeigt das ist
heidecker für heidecker ist schicksal
dasjenige was die menschen zukommt im
augenblick der entscheidung so außerhalb
des täglichen talks außerhalb der des
systematischen kommt kommen diese
augenblicke der entscheidung und dort
wird sich ein mensch bewusst was sein
schicksal ist okay ich weiß nicht ob
schmidt das bei heidegger gelesen hatte
es von der zeitabfolge gerade möglich
aber das ist jetzt nicht so wichtig das
ist diese thematik der die die
wichtigsten inhalte der politik kommen
den menschen in augenblicken im
augenblicklichen ja das ist das ist der
punkt wo dieses diese metaphysische
überhöhung könnte man fast sagen bei
schmidt in erscheinung
ok also ich wollte nur diese drei punkte
zwischen den beiden ein bisschen
hervorheben und auch hervorheben wie
gesagt wie gesagt wie bei schmitt dieses
metaphysische
in dem maß oder eigentlich nicht gar
nicht der fall ist aber gerade wenn wir
bei metaphysischen von metaphysischen
ausgeht haben wir eben auch die tatsache
dass ein bisschen vergleichbarer themen
auch bei benjamin an hochkommen aber bei
benjamin verwendet sie ganz anderes und
das ist das interessante und das werden
wir dann im weiteren verlauf verfolgen
obwohl ich jetzt vorher nächste woche
noch ein bisschen mehr zu schmidt und
den hintergrund laptops sagen möchte ok
also jetzt wollte würde ich jetzt nichts
mehr sagen wenn sie fragen haben also zu
mässig können sie sich melden ich glaube
sie können sich selber freischalten tun
essig oder sie machen es mit chat falls
sie fragen haben
[Musik]
bitte ok
ja